for those that don't know Tick Tock is a
place where people with no Talent get
famous for doing things nearly anyone in
the world can do at any given time
[Music]
things like dancing in your living room
lip-sync into music and flapping your
ass cheeks together oh my god did you
see that hilarious
I'm on the edge of my seat clever
[Music]
this is only gonna get worse isn't it
now that must be what you keep your bath
salts in
[Laughter]
is this you after you crush them up and
shove this video from looks like AOC
this is five months ago it does look
like AOC
you ever wonder who has the most
followers on tick do you know who this
is no it's Charlie demilio she's like
the most famous oh yeah yeah yeah she's
very famous yes she won Dancing With the
Stars she was fantastic by the way she
did a good job oh yeah she deserved it
she's beautiful I gotta give it to her
girl who takes photos of herself in the
mirror yeah 120 million she's got the
blmpfp cavetown not cool all right nah
her family is that it's definitely just
up for the facade though yeah but what
the most followed if it's for a facade
then shame on them and if they also
believe that that organization did
anything I mean think about her
followers
this movement did anything for black
people it's a shame on that it's all
little girl followers oh she finally
changed it she had the BLM profile
picture yeah because I guess I guess all
the black people's problems are solved
now yeah yeah since Biden became
president they're all cool and now so
funny but when Trump was President she
um she did Justice she saved them
all right I don't want to crap on
Charlie as well meanwhile this type of
talent's living in a Subway
[Music]
[Applause]
right here
[Music]
you know what I'm not I'm not I'm not
buying into making fun of those guys
they're in the subway who's making
making a living this whole video is
making fun of tick tock no so you were
saying there's actual good talent oh he
said something positive because yeah I'm
like these guys are out there making a
living playing music in the subway and I
love Subway performers because they they
make the commute so much better agreed
up for that guy
happy
put this [__] on the right on the
other hand
how does she do it folks and why so many
people are having a hard time containing
themselves in the comments this is the
video that put me over the edge
[Music]
I couldn't believe it I called everyone
I knew
another carousela dingleberry is this
all these people do all day and then you
come here and then come like this I mean
look at this look at the planning that
goes into this boom yeah oh
[Music]
I can only imagine what's going on
upstairs here's a girl oh that's that's
it's like giving me the body cringe it's
like that bad oh my God me and my
friends would have killed each other if
anyone ever posted something like that
it would have been barred from the group
chat and you would have had eggs flown
through your window maybe they're
professional dancers those guys and
they're talking about are you still
getting the boys are still flaming you
it doesn't matter I'm sorry that's so
cool covering one of the most difficult
guitar solos ever created probably took
her over a year to learn
[Music]
damn
I could do that
you know what's so funny is that even me
saying like I can do that as like a
sarcastic joke let's say there's like a
hundred thousand people that watch this
video there's still like thousands like
even if only three percent didn't know I
was joking that's still 3 000 people
that are like this kid Sony's an idiot
he couldn't do that right prove it
that's my favorite troll comment prove
it no but sometimes I read the comments
and I'm like how are you real I just
Beyond me sometimes
482 subscribers wow guy wakes up one day
and eats a strawberry 70 million views
10.9 million subscribers asmrs such as
anything of value that inspiration ever
Trend are we just gonna keep mimicking
people who do things anyone can do and
continue to watch each other do it you
know like stretching your mouth with
your finger yeah this is literally a
trend another groundbreaker
zero right teeth I guess
[Music]
foreign
this is what goes on in the rec room of
a nut house and this is what Society
considers influential I don't even
understand what this video would be
though like what would it
personally after this type of behavior
now all these videos are so hard to see
your nieces and nephews
fine I guess you are my little POG champ
come here imagine looking for a house in
this neighborhood and you drive past
this
come here
the other side of the streets
oh my God those are like the ultimate
Lily lilies that's filtered too though
that [__] they need 40 dollars
yup I got my own job yep I got my own
car yep I got my own like where do they
pick up this English
this is just pay my own bills yup
oh yeah you look like Betty Boop and Sid
from Toy Stories illegitimate love child
to me PSA to all the lesbians may I be
the exception come on let me be the
exception
no
imagine that was like your son posting
that stuff
the reason why they're lesbians
[Applause]
[Music]
I love my daddy
my superhero what a tribute his dad must
be so proud what a feeling it must be to
see your son flailing around on a bed
like an injured bird
we're partnering up with a Navy SEAL
friend of ours Tom Shea host a 21 day
virtual event that you guys can join
with us Tom is going to teach you how to
listen to your mind in a new way and how
to control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want so I've seen this process done
for 30 years when you make it through
you will be a different human being the
process is simple but not easy because
of the war that's inside of us the few
people have been taught to fight
overcoming your excuses so if you're
interested in becoming a reformed human
an absolute animal go to tomshay.com and
use Sunny fast50 for 50 off of this
program you will not regret it you will
be a changed person at the end of it do
not miss this the hell is this I'm
losing brain cells watching this
so I'd like to find some Chinese tick
tocks because my understanding is that
in China children are allowed to use
Tick Tock but it is only educational
video they're scrolling I wonder how
true science experience and then they
scroll again and they see a math problem
being solved and then they scroll again
and learn a new language kids wouldn't
scroll on it then yeah but they don't
have this other choice yeah so it's all
they know so their minds are going yes
they they are they are taught who knows
achievement that would be funny they're
taught study achievement honoring your
family with achievement is the good
thing we are taught your family that
your feelings come first that everyone's
out to get you and that this is
entertainment I mean the fact that some
of these videos have hundreds of
millions of views when there's literally
no no no intellectual value whatsoever
and actually extremely low entertainment
value can you stop being an [__]
extremely low entertainment value also
the fact that those two things exist it
really is a an absolute Testament to how
disgusting our education system is here
in the United States and every every
election season we've got politicians
talking about education education
education not one of them in my whole
lifetime has done anything to make it
better in my lifetime I've watched it
get worse and worse and worse and this
is the result and this is the proof that
Americans are being taught to be
brainless half-whits who find this to be
entertaining do not like get your
children off this crap smash their
phones they'll be okay in the end all
right man it's a video just the phone in
her mouth 24 million followers and an
entire account of videos over doing
absolutely nothing in them that's all it
takes folks do nothing the least amount
of effort you put into anything the more
this generational celebrate and admire
you imagine if the grid shut down within
a week these people you know what I was
telling you how like on Tick Tock when
you make a new account because the
algorithm doesn't know you yet and it
doesn't know what you like it pushes out
the videos that are most popular to the
widest audience that's what these are
yeah I call them I'm opening new
accounts for some of our clients and I'm
I call them the NPC videos it is is the
most absolute trash garbage I've ever
seen in my life I it is so unenriching
it's funny it is it is um would be
holding each other on the floor of their
living room yeah
if the grid went down these people would
be you know involved in each other
crying on the floor oh yeah and that is
really [__] sad I wish the grid would
go down now do you see how stupid it
sounds to pretend this is normal human
behavior you know there's something
wrong with our culture when this type of
stuff gets more attention than someone
like this who can paint portraits with
their mouth where's the Netflix
and create things now instead we have
the hype house I've got all my single
boy [__] I've been on my single boy [__]
imagine driving around with a family
looking for a house and you see this
atrocity
look at these kids they act like they're
training for a UFC fight
I could only imagine what's going on
inside
why did I ask looks like some sort of
fertility exercise Jesus these are gonna
be people's grandmothers someday
imagine I just like they're like their
talk was around when the base grandma
was a kid and I had to see like old
videos of her just doing stupid [__]
like that oh you would see her doing the
Lindy you know or um actually you
probably would have seen her running
numbers for her father who was a bookie
but
I got my ticket for the long way around
what was that sounded like she farted at
the end and started crying is that not a
fart
I got my ticket for the lonely van
then she farts and all hell breaks loose
how would you upload the best video that
was on this video I mean how are you
gonna get a job after this circulates or
you could be like this one and embrace
your loose bowels I film all of my fart
videos by myself yo what lighting the
camera the mic what myself this is
crucial for capturing all those high
notes say she made a career out of it
winner game my farts get so loud
sometimes I'll blow out the mic get
ready for this one
see folks we're done we're finished this
is Joey dignity to our species so what
do I need
somewhere
somewhere that was um where's um where's
the link to that fart lady
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram at sunnyvaz join my Discord if
you want a free preview of how I've
generated five million dollars
organically and I'll see you later
[Music]